one of the things I've talked about on
the show and that I often talk about
when I speak to students either in
classes I'm teaching or where I'm
lecturing elsewhere is the idea of bias
by story selection and the concept that
the stories were even aware of in a
particular day if we consume any news at
all and not everybody does represent
this tiny portion some point zero zero
zero I don't know how many zero one
percent of all the stories that we could
have heard about all of the stuff that
happened in a particular day on our
planet and it's really important to
understand why that is and sometimes
it's because of bias the sensationalism
sometimes it's because of advertiser
bias or corporate bias or bias to
availability right the idea that we hear
from the Pentagon on most days on every
cable channel not because there's
actually news from the Pentagon on every
single day but because most news
channels have somebody at the Pentagon
they've got them there already so it's
way cheaper and easier to report
so-called news from that location than
from some other where you might not be
set up so this gets us to a terror
attempt that took place last week at an
airport in the United States you might
be saying well hold on wait what are you
talking about I didn't hear about that
you didn't hear about it because there
was effectively no coverage of it
whatsoever there was silence on this
issue from our president Donald Trump
who usually is very quick to try to take
advantage of any attempted or successful
terrorist attacks to push some or other
harebrained policy and the details of
the story are as follows an Asheville
North Carolina's Airport not long after
midnight on a late night last week a man
who is wearing all black walked into the
terminal was seen on security footage
coming in with a bag and then leaving
without the bag this immediately raised
the suspicions of airport security a
bomb sniffing dog was brought out
sniffed the bag and signaled that there
was something explosive within it and
indeed a I'm sorry
a nfo which is ammonium
trait fuel oil was found inside of it
that's a kind of explosive which
according to the criminal complaint has
been used in a number of terrorist
related incidents around the world and
the way that that material works is that
when an ignition source comes into
contact with it it violently explodes
it's a bomb sometimes metal will be
added to the bomb to create shrapnel and
increase the physical harm that it
causes right you could do sharp nails or
bullets or other stuff both sharp nails
and bullets were actually found in this
bomb now again you're probably hearing
me say this and you're thinking David
that's major an attempted terrorist
attack with a shrapnel Laden bomb found
in an American Airport and we didn't
hear about it
well the alarm on the bomb was scheduled
to go off at 6:00 a.m. meaning that this
was found a few hours before it actually
exploded the man in question was found
he openly admitted to authorities that
he was preparing to quote fight a war on
US soil a bomb against whom and on whose
behalf we don't actually know
so why didn't we hear about it now it's
very easy to say well David we didn't
hear about it because it was foiled
wrong we hear about foiled attacks all
the time but it depends on the
particulars of the attack and of the
would-be perpetrator this was just
another American white guy what if this
foiled attack with a shrapnel Laden bomb
at an American Airport had been Muslim
that would then have been reported and
used as justification for the travel ban
by the President of the United States
what if this would-be perpetrator had
been Hispanic well then it would have
been justification for the wall with
Mexico because some I'm sure good people
but they're not exactly sending us our
best but it was just your average
American white guy who was his war even
against I don't know but he was one of
these white militia types that we've
been hearing more and more about from
groups that track extremists like the
anti-defamation league so the
fundamental point to be made here is
that if you make a big deal out of this
foiled terrorist attack by
that American white guy it doesn't
advance any political agenda our safety
agenda would benefit from us realizing
that it's mostly white Americans who
commit terror in the United States the
safety agenda would be advanced by
realizing that the political agenda of
the American right is advanced only when
there is a pretext right Muslims
Hispanics whatever if the incident
foiled or successful can provide a
pretext for legislation that the right
wants to pass that's when we hear about
it and it's very popular to frame the
threat as an external one that we can
insulate ourselves against if we keep
the right people out of the country but
once again it's not and again you didn't
hear about this because it did not serve
the current administration's political
agenda the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership